great education yeah because i told him
i didn't want to get a certain vehicle
because of the amount of gas i would
have to spend it cost like eighty
dollars to fill it up
and he said
then you said when it gets to half then
you put 20 odds you bring it back to
full yeah but if i keep i would have to
stop off and still 180. no you wouldn't
no you wouldn't why you're complaining
about when it gets to zero you'll spend
80. right when it gets to half you put
20 then when you get back to have you
put 20. yeah but i keep stopping putting
20 in it'll be 80 the same amount of gas
i'm driving the same amount of gas the
average human stops once a week for gas
right which you you only work here twice
you would probably have to stop maybe
maybe once every two weeks
don't even try it this is all this is
borderline travel more than me this is
bordering on what's closer the west
coast or the moon so if i if you're
bordering on that you're cool you're
you're telling me that i would i
wouldn't have to if i only if i didn't
let my guys get down i wouldn't have to
fill it up as much
no i'm saying you're complaining about
the eighty dollars that's what the
conversation about you you're well four
times twenty is eighty cause i'm gonna
stop four times yeah no you're not gonna
stop four times no you're not gonna stop
four times not in one week you're not
anyway
the west coast is closer than the moon
if you let it get to zero right monday
through friday right then you got to pay
80 to fill it back up right okay but if
you let it get to half by wednesday then
you pay 20.
right but if wednesday it's going to be
40 and then on fridays will be 40 20.
it's gonna be 20. no
it's gonna be 20. about half
half of 80 is 40. but no this is what
i'm saying i i am okay so if i every day
if i didn't if i said you're
don't play me right now i'm not playing
don't [ __ ] with me right now
i'm sorry
i really want to know because ernie i
want to get this card without listen you
want to save gas money you're completely
telling this
you're complaining about the 80 dollars
yes right so i'm confident okay so 0 is
80. no question all right at full it's
80 right yes if it gets a half that
would be 40 right oh question if you put
20 and then you bring it back up to
three quarters
right no if i put 20 in it let's get to
one coin geez yeah but it'll be three
quarters it'd be three quarters full
three quarts empty no three quarters
full but who's off first
you know what
[Laughter]
nobody travels more than me no just just
listen we have we've heard it so many
times check how much gas you think you
can get for twenty dollars right now but
listen for kids
forget gas prices forget all that good
amount how can you forget gas prices
listen man
if you're empty right right you're empty
no not empty if you have you're half
full yeah if you give 21 dollars that
you're that's just going to give you
some more cushion to play around
that's all i'm saying play around where
rather than rather than rather than
going all the way to the bottom and
spending 50 60. can i see what you could
have
at that 20 that's going to bring it back
up to three quarters
how many years have we been having this
thing i just have one question like
three years because you already
listening now i have one question
okay
if i'm if i need to go 30 miles bro
don't don't i'll just answer the
question
i answered your question don't hit me
with no i got to go 30 miles i don't
care about how many and my car goes
five
miles per gallon
and i have six gallons i'm not listening
to three gallons in there forget about
that
shut the hell up
it don't matter how much i put in i
can't go further than
i got to get 30 miles i'm not talking
about this i'm talking about if i had if
i'm in half i don't want to keep driving
but where are you driving shut up
does it matter if i might have and i
keep driving i'm going to go down but if
i'm at half and i get 20.
driving matters that's that's all i'm
saying if you're driving around the
corner yes are you listening to me
yeah i'm going from your house to the
studio right if i'm at half oh his house
you're not getting there you're not
you're not
i'm just saying if you're in half and i
drive from your house it's going to
bring it down to the negative if i add
20 just going to give me some cushions
all right ain't no question
and then you'll be back here tomorrow
case closed shut the hell up all of you
case closed indeed yes please trust me
my gas method works yes this is going to
be on the side of the road